За сімома замками, у спеціальній кімнаті-холодильнику зі стабільною температурою
і суворо обмеженим доступом. Саме так зберігається вакцина Covishield,
якою вже другий тиждень вакцинують медиків в Україні.
Перевіряємо температуру. Сьогодні отримали 10 доз.
Аби щепити від коронавірусу колег-медиків, ця бригада у складі сімейного лікаря
і двох медсестер щодня долає сотні кілометрів на Житомирщині.
Зазвичай Лариса і Валентина працюють у пункті щеплень однієї з лікарень Коростеня.
Але останні 10 днів вони постійно в дорозі. Бо поки єдині у регіоні,
хто пройшов спеціальне навчання і має дозвіл вакцинувати від COVID-19.
Хоча, кажуть, принцип роботи з Covishield суттєво не відрізняється від інших вакцин.
Хіба що надмірною увагою до препарату та кількістю відмов від нього.
У нас дуже багато людей відмовлялися один час. Якась така була антивакцинарна кампанія.
А зараз краще це все йде. Мені здається, що люди сумніваються тому,
що вона виготовлена на території Індії. Але ми їм пояснюємо,
чому вона там виготовлена, що це є вакцина AstraZeneca. І багато хто передумують.
Переноситься вона дуже добре. Побічних ефектів майже не має.
В одному флаконі вакцини Covishield міститься 10 доз.
Робити ін’єкції можна протягом 6 годин з моменту відкриття ампули.
Якщо цей час сплив, а охочих вакцинуватися не знайшлося, препарат доводиться просто виливати.
Ми зазвичай використовуємо всі дози. У нас лише один раз розлив був 8 доз,
люди відмовилися. Утилізували її. Ця вакцина не замочується,
вона виливається в контейнер для утилізації. Шкода, звичайно,
їх виливати, хочеться зробити, щоб воно не пропало, бо це ж усе гроші.
Медсестра Лариса та її напарники по бригаді самі від COVID-19 поки не щеплені.
При цьому вколоти залишки препарату собі, аби не виливати його, не мають права.
Це не передбачено протоколом. Хоча минулого тижня МОЗ таки ухвалив рішення
про щеплення невикористаними дозами громадських діячів та авторитетних українців.
Після масових відмов українських лікарів вакцинуватися та дискусій довкола того,
чи є Covishield повним аналогом препарату AstraZeneca, щеплення публічно
отримав міністр охорони здоров’я Максим Степанов та президент Володимир Зеленський.
Частину першу зробили. Зробили прекрасно. Нічого не болить. Всім рекомендую.
У Черняхівському територіальному медичному об’єднанні одразу після прибуття бригади
вишиковується черга з охочих щепитися медиків. Однак це лише 19 із 43 медиків,
які мали б отримати щеплення у першій хвилі. Решта відмовилася.
Ольга Степанівна - медсестра у сільській амбулаторії. Вона чула про відмову багатьох колег
щепитися від коронавірусу. Для неї це стало ще одним аргументом за вакцинацію.
У мене в селі є випадки захворювання на коронавірус, лежали люди мої в стаціонарі.
Я вважаю, що я буду більш захищена, бо я спілкуюся з цими хворими.
А медпрацівники, які не хочуть щепитися, хочуть подивитися,
як буде протікати ця перша хвиля щеплення. Потім будуть вони теж щеплюватися.
Треба показати їм приклад, що ми не боїмося і хочемо щепитися.
За словами головного лікаря Черняхівського територіального медичного об’єднання,
дехто з медиків має протипоказання до вакцинації. Є й ті, хто не пояснює причин відмови,
і мають на це право, адже вакцинація добровільна. Частина медиків аргументують відмову від Covishield
наявністю антитіл після вже перенесеної хвороби.
Сімейна лікарка Ірина Ніколайчук попри те, що перехворіла коронавірусом декілька місяців тому,
вирішила все одно вакцинуватися і пояснює необхідність цього своїм пацієнтам.
Я відчула на собі, що значить просто навіть легкий перебіг коронавірусної хвороби.
Дуже хотілося б захистися від цього в подальшому і не відчувати цього ніколи-ніколи.
Вакцина досить свіжа, нова, рекомендована до використання тільки в екстрених ситуаціях
- таких, як пандемія. А люди у нас звикли до препаратів, які тривало розроблялися,
доказову базу мають. І то не завжди вони довіряють, їм легше сходити до бабки
і повірити в якусь травичку,
тому це нюанси нашої психології - і тут треба дійсно працювати.
В українському представництві ЮНІСЕФ недовіру до вакцини Covishield
вважають наслідком інформаційної кампанії, що несе загрозу боротьбі з пандемією в країні.
Існує багато помилкових думок і дезінформації, які ми називаємо інфодемією подібно до пандемії.
Тому що наразі це заполонило соціальні мережі. І люди, які не здатні перевірити факти
і докази, вірять у це. І це дуже погано, адже може згодом призвести до того,
що вони не отримають щеплення, навіть отримавши доступ до вакцини.
Аби подолати хвилю дискусій щодо безпечності вакцини Covishiled, українські лікарі
запустили флешмоб у соцмережах, де діляться досвідом вакцинації та пояснюють її важливість іншим.
Житомирський лікар-анестезіолог Василь Шутенко щоденно робить те саме.
Тільки не в мережі, а у "ковідному" відділенні, куди щодня потрапляє дедалі більше хворих.
Він першим отримав вакцину від COVID-19 у своєму регіоні.
Я коли перший раз захворів майже рік тому, були аналогічні прояви.
Я кажу, що це ковід екстерном, протягом 4-12 годин. Біль у суглобах, ось і все.
У деяких моїх колег була температура незначна від 37 до 38.
У перший день вакцинувалися 40 працівників лікарні. На сьогодні, коли вже побачили,
як-то кажуть, що ми вижили, вже дзвонять, питають, коли буде наступний етап.
Уже кількість тих, хто погоджується, збільшується.
Василь Шутенко чекає другої дози вакцини Covishield і вірить, що щеплення
- єдиний спосіб повернутися до нормального життя без пандемії.
Хочу аналог провести. Натуральна віспа, вірус. До 78-го року всі були щеплені в світі.
Ми побороли вірус, вірус, який нині знаходиться в лабораторії. У природі його на щастя не реєструють.
Так само можна зробити з "ковідом", зробити щеплення, зробити колективний імунітет
і таким чином пандемію ліквідувати, щоб ми змогли зняти маски і нарешті побачити усміхнені обличчя.
Наразі через збільшення кількості хворих на COVID-19 в Україні чотири області,
у тому числі й Житомирська, опинилися у червоній зоні.
Кількість пацієнтів, яких щоденно госпіталізують до стаціонару "ковідних" відділень тут стрімко зростає.
Ми вже можемо казати про третю хвилю. Ситуація наразі контрольована.
Але разом з тим 42% ліжок, які зараз завантажені, дають величезне навантаження на наших лікарів,
на нашу медичну систему. Вакцинація - це те, що допоможе нам подолати "ковід".
Я тепер у цьому вже впевнений. Я для себе вирішив, що, напевно, я, як і президент України
та міністр охорони здоров’я, теж буду вакцинуватися. І це, напевно,
буде найкращим меседжем для людей про те, що це потрібно.
За перші 10 днів вакцинації від COVID-19 в Україні її отримали більше 19 тисяч осіб.
Водночас понад 160 тисяч українців записалися на щеплення від коронавірусу через додаток "Дія".
Утім, за прогнозами експертів, загальнодоступними вакцини в Україні стануть лише наприкінці літа.
До того їх робитимуть лише визначеним категоріям громадян, як-от медики,
військовослужбовці, соцпрацівники та люди, що перебувають
у спеціальних закладах на кшталт інтернатів.